[Applaudissements]
alors là à lavau l'attendait il en pense
quoi ton frère le génie encore taper
voilà qu ils en pensent quoi ton frère
c'est simple voilà qui pose des
questions aux gens pendant qu'ils nous
répondent on part très très vite se
déguiser dans un camion et on revient à
billets comme eux peu près 1 c'est pas
avatar non plus un regard du web de
system of the person
je trouve que le métro français était
exceptionnelle et votre frein il en
pense quoi à mon frère lui il n'est pas
du tout
[Rires]
quand même une caméra cachée andry mal
cachée mais stressant quand même et à ça
on pense quoi elle habite à toulouse
donc juste nous on prend plus avec ma
soeur on prend plus les transports parce
que ça fait quand même deux semaines
touche ça avec kevin et il ya un scout
il a un typhoon
donc ça nous permet de circuler partout
en revanche on voudrait passer un gros
bisou à kim kardashian et si elles
peuvent ajouter sur install et qu'il se
balançait salue sa voix peur des bush au
nom des autres blocs de bois et votre
frère il en pense quoi
en fait oui votre frère l'on pense quoi
il est assez positive pour le boulot ici
mais je fais des passes tout en taxi en
fait et votre frère elle en pense quoi
mon frère frère mon frère cheikh pas
loger caste
j'aime les gens pensent à lui est en
concert demain soir à tony garnier
j'ai bien ciao
[Musique]